today we're gonna catch our discussion
of savings I continue my nagging on you
guys about how you should be saving
money and then we're gonna move on and
talk about international trade so let's
finish our discussion of savings
now savings turns out to be a critically
important element of growth in the
economy and we've now traced through why
that happens okay our basic story is
that savings goes up as savings goes up
that means that the capital supply
shifts out so this habit of supply curve
shift outward as people save more
that's an increase in the capital supply
curve in the capital markets that means
that interest rates fall okay because
there's more supply for a given demand
the price is gonna fall the price of
capital is the interest rate so as
people save more that's more supplying
to capital markets it's increasing the
pool from which firms have to borrow for
a given pool firms have to pay less
money to borrow from that if the
interest rate goes down that means the
NPV of investment goes up because
remember the net present value
investment is a negative function of the
interest rate the lower the interest
rate the more firms will say I might as
well buy a new machine because the
bank's not paying me anything okay that
means that NPV investment goes up which
means the investment goes up so the
bottom line is the way we get firms to
invest more and grow the economy
is by saving more we save more we
increase capital supply that lowers the
interest rate that raises the NPV of
investment which leads to more
investment so that's the link by which
savings Leath economic growth is that
savings leads firm to invest more okay
is that clear from this sort of
structure we built in the last couple
lectures okay if it's not just go back
through and work through the math but
you'll see we talked about the
capital market the interest rates the
price in the capital market last time we
talked about the interest rate this the
lower the industry the higher than that
present value of any given investment
that means firms will invest more so
that means a critical public policy
concern is getting people to save enough
now obviously that varies with economic
conditions in a deep recession we don't
actually want as much savings we're not
in recession but in general in the long
run we will grow more as an economy if
we save more as a society and the u.s.
is an incredible low savings rate our
savings rate in the u.s. depending how
you define in is maybe three to five
percent in Europe in Japan it's like
fifteen plus percent okay so we have a
very low savings rate and as a result
that has led public policymakers to try
to think about tools they can use to
encourage savings and the major tool we
use in public policy to encourage
savings is the tax subsidy to retirement
savings the tax subsidy to retirement
savings is the major tool that we use to
increase savings in the US okay and how
does this work okay the basic logic is
the following when I put my money in the
bank and I earn interest that interest
gets taxed just like my labor supply
gets taxed my capital income gets taxed
okay so when I put money in the bank I
don't just throw in the interest rate
well make use art where we care about
real and trade I don't use the learning
in straight iron are times 1 minus taw
we're tars the tax rate that's all I
take home so the bank's takes me ten
percent say inflation zero so nominal
interest rates are the same to make
pigmies ten percent and my tax rates 50
percent I only take home five percent on
that okay if we assume substitution
effects dominate which is the big
assumption but a typically one we make
this will lead this means the taxation
by lowering the return to savings will
lead to less savings so might
acting's people's savings we lead to
less of it because we sort of assumed
substitution effects dominated
okay to offset this we say well I'll
tell you what if you save for retirement
we won't tax it so if you save didn't
you pull it out next year we're gonna
tax it but if you put it in special
accounts which we've labeled as
retirement savings we won't tax it okay
so these have a number of forms one form
is employer sponsored pensions these are
things where your employer takes some of
your pay puts it aside in an account and
when he does that
you're not taxed on that pay so if MIT
if MIT is gonna pay me a hundred
thousand dollars and they pull ten
thousand aside and put into pension I'm
only taxed on ninety thousand that ten
thousand isn't taxed and likewise the
interest that's earned on that isn't
texts okay there's also 401 k s-- a 401
k is like a pension but where you
control the money so when you get a job
you might get off with a 401 k that's
something where some of your money gets
pulled out of your salary it doesn't get
taxed and it gets saved instead and you
control where it goes okay and then we
also have individual retirement accounts
under the unfortunately IRA there's not
the irish republican army but individual
retirement accounts which are similar
features where you could take their
money and save it on a tax-free basis
okay now here's the trick about how all
these things work is they're not
actually tax-free they are tax deferred
and what do I mean by that what I mean
by that is that when you take the money
out eventually it does get taxed so the
way say your 401 K would work you get a
job at you know whatever some say you
know at Google Google Offers your 401 K
you put money in it that money that
accumulates and when you take it out you
put money in that money's not taxed when
you put it in well you take it out it is
taxed okay so it is eventually taxed
so why would that what good is that do
you what good does that do you it's
gonna get taxed eventually anyway yeah
right it takes advantage of present
value more we talked about this last
time with present value money in the
future is worth less than money today by
the same logic
paying taxes in the future cost you less
than paying taxes today because you have
the money today you can earn all the
same suristan it and you have to pay
taxes on it off in the future so let's
see an example of that let's look at
figure eighteen one okay let's say you
have two types of accounts a regular
account or an IRA account which is a tax
deferred account and let's say the tax
rate is 25% and the interest rate is 10%
and let's say you're just gonna put the
money in to make life easy imagine you
put the money for when your imagine
retiring next year this is a super easy
example you're retiring next year the
questions for this last year of work
should you put your money in a tax
deferred account or in a regular account
okay well if you put it in the regular
account you will take your hundred
dollars earnings to pay twenty five
dollars of taxes right away so you only
get to put 75 dollars in on that seventy
five dollars drill earn 750 and when you
take the 750 out you'll pay a dollar
eighty eight in taxes okay so you paid
$25 on your earnings you pay another
dollar eighty eight on the interest you
earn and you end up with eighty dollars
and sixty-two cents now let's say
instead you set up an IRA well there you
get to put the whole hundred in that
hundred dollars earns ten dollars and
when you take out the hundred ten
dollars then you pay tax on it so you
pay twenty seven fifty then in the end
but if you put it all together you end
up with more money
8250 rather than eighty sixty two why is
that it's because you delayed paying
taxes by a year by paying taxes one year
later you got to earn the interest on
that money during the year think of it
this way if you pay taxes now the
government gets the money and they get
to earn interest on it if you pay taxes
next year you keep the money in your
interest on it so it's much better to
pay taxes later and that's why the
counts matter this is a simple example
okay it's a simple example if you have a
30 year account if we kept the interest
rate of 10% and the tax rate of 25% and
did a 30-year calculation you would have
twice as much money
after 30 years if you put an IRA rather
than putting a regular bank account so
even though it eventually gets taxed
it's a big advantage it's a big
advantage and that's why we think that's
why public policy introduced these tools
401ks pensions IRAs because they're
trying to encourage saving by raising
the return to saving okay and they hope
that by encouraging saving they'll get
all this good stuff coming out of it so
that's why these things come up so the
first lesson is 401 just like my
continued nag on you it's savory and
save often things like 401 KS by putting
your money away not only did the
compounding I talked about before but
you also get the tax benefit of paying
taxes later rather than sooner okay get
the compounding on the money and the
compounding on the taxes okay
so these kinds of retirement accounts
when you get your job and you're
thinking about why would I worry about
retirement worried about retirement
there's a big there's a big advantage
now then you ask me okay that's fine
John but when I get my 401 K paperwork
I've got like a million things I can
invest in what do I do with the money so
let's talk for a couple minutes about
investment strategy about what you do
with the money okay so let's think about
three different ways you can invest your
retirement money three class of options
a 401 K will typically have they'll
typically be a money market fund market
fund a bond fund and a stock fund and
then we various combinations of these
but these are the categories what do
these mean money market means the
money's invested in government bonds
okay the money's invested or what call
Treasury security
government bonds these are things which
are ultra safe as long as the US doesn't
default on its debt which we've never
done in our history and the good Lord
willing we won't do in the near term
well if US doesn't default on its debt
you get paid back
these are super safe it's the safest
place you can put your money but they
pay a very low interest rate right now
they're paying interest rates the
typical government bond fund right now
be paying interest at around sort of
maybe 2% to 2/3 maybe 1 to 2% very low
interest rate maybe up to 3 now but very
very low single digits but totally safe
a bond fund invests your money in
corporate bonds these are basically this
is making loans to corporations instead
of flowing the mind of the government
you loan them under corporation you're
not actually buying a bond in GM that's
too hard so what these 401k accounts do
is they say we're gonna buy a bunch of
bonds we're gonna put them together and
let you own own a small piece of that
entire set of bonds that's what a bond
fund is ok so you're a small piece a
bunch of corporate bonds the difference
is unlike the government corporations do
go out of business all the time so these
are riskier
okay these are riskier but they pay a
higher interest rate bond funds
typically are paying 4 to 5 percent
right now okay then finally the last
thing in your mind is you can put it in
stocks you can literally own corporate
equity you can own a piece of companies
okay you can own a piece of the
companies and then what you get is you
get something it doesn't really matter
with these two it only matters you get
paid as long as the company or the
government of the company don't go out
of business here you get paid in
proportion to how well the company does
if it does really well you make a lot of
money stock prices go up because badly
you lose money if it goes bankrupt you
lose everything okay so similarly these
in the bankruptcy cost you everything
the difference is these are either you
get paid or you go bankrupt here and you
get bet it's much more variable things
do well you get more things go badly you
get less so this is the riskiest option
of all
but it also pays the highest rate of
return traditionally stock investments
pay along where to retire about seven
percent a year so what we see here we
compare these is what economists call
the risk return trade-off the risk
return trade-off the riskier things are
the higher you earn by investing in them
but the riskier that earnings is the
more you're investing them but the risk
you that earnings is okay that in other
words people are willing to accept a
lower interest rate for a safe
investment then they want for a risky
investment and we'll talk about in the
next lecture in two lectures from now
why that is why people's preferences are
that way it's because people are what we
call risk averse people don't like risk
and we'll talk about why that's a
natural way to be okay so basically that
is your set of choices and what
economists recommend is that the key in
all these investments is to diversify
the key recommendation of economists is
diversification that you put your money
you spread your money across these
options to get the right balance of risk
and return okay so that basically if
you're someone if if you're someone who
now how you balance depends on your
taste for rich there's no one who really
hates risk you put most of your money
here but it's silly to put all your
money in money markets because you're
losing out a lot of return if you're
someone who's risk loving you might want
to put most - money in stocks but still
put all your money in stocks because
you're you have a hot much higher risk
you want some safety behind you as well
so economists would say you should
diversify now that's a general I can't
tell you what percentage is the right
percentages are you telling diversified
but I can give you one specific piece of
advice that when you go work for company
X the one thing you do not want to do is
put your money in the stock of company X
why is that
why is the last thing we wanted you when
you go to work for company x2 put a
bunch of your money in the stock of
company X yeah no I know this would be
through a 401k 401k account it wouldn't
be like that yeah that is the maximally
risky strategy because you are tying
your risk of your investments to your
risk of your salary okay that's the most
risky thing you can do okay so
absolutely what you would not want to do
is go work for Google and say oh good
I'm going all my retirement in Google
stock you might think Google's safe but
safer copies in Google at the Cubbies
thought to be safely Google at some
point I've gone bankrupt who else
bankrupt you're totally screwed you've
lost all your savings and your job so
last thing you wanna do is that yeah
well I mean certainly a lot of companies
give you stock options where you're sort
of stuck in the stock of that company
and my little lesson there would be well
that's part of conversation but as soon
as it vest sell it and get out okay that
doesn't mean you shouldn't you should
you should values it's not saying stock
options at a company are worthless
they're worth something it's just
they're worth less than if they just
gave you the cash because you got the
cash and go invest it in somewhere that
wouldn't be tied to your job okay and
this came to a head with the example of
Enron which is sort of before your time
okay that's sort of when you were young
but basically Enron was an energy
company that got into some really shady
dealings to try to essentially prop up
its stock price to make itself look
valuable it essentially created shell
companies that were the same company and
sold to them so like it was generating a
lot of sales was just selling to itself
okay leaked it was a legal activity but
it caused their stock price to go
through the roof and Enron in order to
have enough money in the company
encourage their employees to invest all
the retirement savings at Enron indeed
the Enron 401k said we'll give you extra
money in your account if you invest your
money in Enron
so most people Enron had their
retirement saving invested at Enron when
the whole thing and Enron was a very
successful company very heating in the
and 500 doing quite well when the whole
thing collapsed diesel anomaly lost
their jobs they lost their entire
savings okay that's the problem not on
diversification and the open for non
diversification is to invest in the
company you're working for okay have a
scared us any questions about that okay
now let's move on that finishes our
discussion of savings let's move on to a
totally new topic which we'll talk about
this lecture in the rest of next lecture
which is international trade and let's
start with what is international trade
and why the ruckus this is a great time
to view an international trade probably
the best most exciting time is the of
any year I've ever taught this topic its
front and center in a way it hasn't been
probably in decades so what's the big
deal
well let's talk about a simple example
how many people have ever given someone
roses for Valentine's Day
raise your hands a mighty man all right
uh okay that's okay when I was your age
I hadn't either
um now here's an interesting problem
with Valentine's Day Valentine's Day
falls in the winter roses don't grow
outside in the cold in the winter so
what do you do well for many years what
we did was we had hot houses where we
grew basically were dedicated the very
reason for existing was to essentially
grow Valentine's Day roses such an
industry around growing these indoor
roses in the winter so that you could so
you could have them available but what
happened over time is we realize it was
a lot cheaper tax just buy the roses in
Colombia or countries like that and fly
them up then to actually have them grown
here so what happened was we all now get
all the roses we get now in the winter
come from South America okay and we
don't grow roses in America anymore in
the winter so is that a good thing or a
bad thing well in the one end roses are
a ton cheaper now than where when I was
a kid okay so that's a good thing for
the Romantics among us you can get a
does he get a rope dozen roses for 25
bucks it was like 80 bucks another kid
or something how's crazy okay on the
other hand a bunch of guys used to grow
these roses are added
there was an industry devoted to growing
these roses and these people now have no
job because they're grown somewhere else
so how do we think about this trade-off
is sort of a microcosm of the larger
debate around international trade the
larger debate about whether trade is
good or bad comes down to this roses
example it sort of summarizes that issue
so now we think about international
trade we think about three concepts we
think about exports which are the amount
of goods that we sell to other countries
okay and imports where - the amount of
goods that we buy from other countries
so a country exports to other countries
it imports from other countries okay
currently the u.s. exports about 1.6
trillion dollars of goods a year that's
what that's trillion with the tea and
imports about two point four trillion
dollars of goods a year leaving us with
an 800 billion trade deficit you may
have heard the president mention this
once or twice okay and I heard your
billion dollar trade deficit so the
question want to ask is how big a
problem is this that we have a trade
deficit and the answer economists give
is none problem okay
no no spinal tap fancier okay whatever
okay so basically let's explain this at
a simple example imagine that you have
two Pikachu's and your friend has two
Jigglypuff's okay and you want to have a
more diverse set of Pokemon so you go to
your friend and you say I will trade you
one Pikachu for one Jigglypuff so you
send your friend a Pikachu he sends you
a Jigglypuff you've just created a
massive Pikachu deficit think about it
used to have - Pikachu's you sent one
away you
you said we didn't get any Pikachu's
back did you so you've created a huge
deficit of one Pikachu is that bad
no you got a tickly puff you're happy
you want to make the trade you made the
trade calling the trade deficit define
trade deficit in terms of if you define
traitors instead of terms of
Jigglypuff's you've got a huge trade
surplus you used to get no G to the
puffs now you get one so what basically
a trade EV straight circle is all about
an arbitrary definition the bottom line
is America sin spends eight hundred
billion dollars more you're sending
money to other countries but we get 800
billion dollars a year more stuff for it
there's no bad or good
it's just the way trade works okay so
anytime you've had a trade in your life
of anything with a friend or whatever
you've created a deficit and a surplus
but that doesn't mean anyone's worse off
or better off whether worse not better
off depends on the indicators of the
trade depends on how much each party
values what's going on okay so basically
if I said oh good lord
find a headline good lord you know
Gruber creates Pikachu deficit must end
trade with Jigglypuff land okay and we
must shut down trade because good lord
where we're creating this huge Pikachu
deficit that would be bad because I
wanted to trade my ticket you for
Jigglypuff I was happier okay that would
be a bad thing to shut that off and that
in stupid example is why economists like
international trade okay it's the same
reason we like trade in general think
about this whole course so course about
bit about trade it's about been training
our money for cookies a pizza about
trading a firm's money for workers and
machines okay about trading my time for
a wage life is all about trades
international trades just another
example of that Jessica's got this
bizarre label of a trade deficit we
think about it differently okay so
that's sort of basically if you think
think about now let's replace Pikachu
and Jigglypuff with the US and a poor
country instead of us having two
Pikachu's do you
has tons of money instead of the poor
country having to Jigglypuff's the poor
country has really underpaid workers who
can make stuff really cheaply so I am
USA wait I have a lot of money you got a
lot of sweaters I'm gonna send you my
money and get your sweaters I'm better
off because I was happy to buy those
sweaters cheaply
you're better off because you can't eat
sweaters you need money so you get some
of my money
we're both better off but I've created a
trade deficit okay that is not
inherently a problem now of course the
reality is more complicated the reality
is that when I send in the money to
those countries to buy the sweaters and
I bring the sweaters in my consumers of
sweaters are much happier and I keep
focusing on sweaters because it's just
amazing okay this sweater I just got at
Old Navy okay $15 pretty nice decent
you know it's not cotton whatever $15
this would have been a fortune when I
was your age okay it knows these dollars
it would have been $30 and that would be
like $70 today okay why China okay
because we used to movies to make these
in North Carolina now we make them in
China okay so the good news is I went to
Old Navy I got two pairs of pants and
like four sweaters like a hundred bucks
okay that's the good news okay the bad
news is the guys North Carolina lost
their jobs that's the bad news so
there's a trade-off
now I'm gonna argue over the next
lecture and a half that that trade-off
is worth it in aggregate but we can't
ignore the fact there's a trade-off
because that's what leads to the very
intense debates around your national
trade is the fundamental tension between
the consumers of goods that are made
cheaper by the international trade and
the producers of goods that get wiped
out by international trade okay so
that's our setup that's our big picture
now I'm gonna dive in and I'm gonna
teach you the nitty-gritty of how we
think about this with models but that's
the big picture once you have in mind so
let's dive into the models that you do
the models I need introduced a new a new
tool to you which is the production
possibility frontier
PPF the production possibility frontier
what the PPF shows you is the maximum
combination of outputs you can produce
for any given set of inputs okay so
basically let's think about that let's
go to figure 18 - it's easier to see
this graphically let's go to figure 18 -
let's think of you as a firm and you as
a firm produce two things problem set
points and exam points sorry it's all
you're good for at MIT here you produce
problem set points and exam points but
you can produce either those you two
things you produce and to make life easy
let's say given your innate intelligence
the points are produced as a function of
time
literally the more time you put in
studying for an exam the better you do
the more time you're spending the
problem sets they better you do and you
have one scarce input which is time this
production possibility frontier tells
you if you devote your scarce input
across different activities what will
the result be in terms of what's
produced so what's this line saying on
the left-hand side is saying look if I
put all my time into studying for exams
I'll get 200 points at exams and zero on
problem sets if I spend all my time
doing problem sets I've got 200 points
on problem sets and zero on exams and
some combinations in between that is a
production possibility frontier okay it
shows the combination of outputs you get
for any given fixed level of inputs now
what is wrong with the graph on the left
and why is the graph on the right
probably more realistic description of
what your actual production possibility
frontier looks like
yeah yeah it's wrong because in fact
what this system features is something
we call economies of scope we talked
about economies of scale a number of
lectures ago the notion that when if you
double inputs do you double output this
economies of scope which is that by
producing more than one thing at once
you may get better at both let by
studying for an exam you get better at
problem sets and by doing problem sets
you do better on the exam so what that
means is doing some of both leads to a
better outcome than doing all of one or
all the other okay you get a concave to
the origin production possibility
frontier a concave larger production
possibility frontier demonstrates the
economies of scope doing some of both is
better than doing all of just one all
the other and that makes sense for you
and doing problem sets in exams it makes
sense you'd be better off doing some of
both than devoting all your attention to
one and just just one in just the other
okay
so that is a production possibility
frontier now there can also be dis
economies of scope another great example
for MIT is that when I was here as an
undergrad I came in as a tennis player
and I was on the tennis team now tennis
was only in the fall and spring in the
winter they had squash so I thought I'd
play squash well it turns out that the
key with tennis is keeping your wrist on
the huge squash is keeping your wrist
flexible and by playing squash I screwed
up my tennis game am i playing tennis I
screwed up my swashy a squash game so I
had a diseconomy of scope
I was worse off at both things by
playing both the ribbon is just playing
one or the other okay
so it can be economies of scope which is
when doing both things make you better
at both and diseconomies a scoop when
doing both things make you worse at both
okay and that's the nature of the shape
of production possibilities frontier and
the economy of scope is when doing both
makes you better off a dis economy of
scope is when doing both makes you're
worse off okay questions about that
now it just ensures that tool because
that tool it could be the fundamental
modeling feature that allows us to
demonstrate why international trade is
beneficial okay so now we're gonna take
that tool and we're gonna go and talk
about the concept of comparative
advantage which is the core concept in
international trade economics this is
the core of how it all works okay let's
think of a particular example to
understand this let's take the US and
Colombia and the Rose market okay and as
I said before let's say it's expensive
for the u.s. in the Valentine's Day rose
market it's expensive for the us to grow
Valentine's Day roses it's cheap in
Colombia okay on the other hand let's
compare roses to computers roses are
cheap to produce in Colombia and
expensive in America computers are the
opposite we have giant factories and
skilled labor and giant machines that
can quickly crank out computers in
Colombia that have to like assemble the
computer by hand okay so it's a lot
cheaper to produce a computer in the US
than it is in Colombia it's a lot
cheaper to produce a rose in Colombia
that is in the US the way to think about
this is through the lens of opportunity
cost what we're saying is the
opportunity cost of making a rose in
terms of computers is higher in the US
you know though it's the amount of
computers you have to give up to make a
rose is high in u.s. because computers
are cheap and roses are expensive the
amount of computers you have to the
command of roses you have to give up to
make computer in Columbia's higher
because roses are cheaper computers are
expensive so we say that Colombia has a
comparative advantage in roses is
relatively cheap in a world of computers
and roses
is relatively cheap for them to produce
roses compared to computers the
opportunity cost entrance of argon
computers is lower whereas the US has a
comparative advantage in computers it is
comparatively cheaper for us to produce
computers so international trade is all
about what you're relatively better at
now let me emphasize relative for a
second this is an important concept the
reason we don't just say advantage and
we say comparative advantage is it
doesn't actually matter if you're better
it matters you're relatively better let
me explain this is hard this is I would
say of the main economics constants in
the world that we need people understand
this is one of the top three least
understood concepts in all the world
okay in economics credit vanch like in
our blood we can understand my regular
people can understand it it's because
it's hard ok let me give you let me give
an example take me and LeBron James and
imagine his two activities in life
mowing a lawn and playing basketball
that's all life consisteth ok now LeBron
James is better than me at both playing
basketball and mowing along but he's
much much much much much better than me
at basketball and only much better than
me and rolling along
so LeBron James has an advantage in
everything both activities but he only
has a comparative advantage in
basketball he only is a comparative a
ninja best the pair advantage is about
opportunity costs in other words the
amount it's LeBron James mows his lawn
the amount of basketball he's giving up
is ungodly it's crazy I mow his lawn
give me my bachelor could have played if
I mow my lawn I'm not giving orange
basketballs I suck at basketball so I
have a comparative advantage in lawn
mowing might say how could your not
better at lawn when LeBron James I'm not
but I have a comparative antigen in lawn
mowing because the opportunity cost to
me is much lower the opportunity costs
LeBron James of mowing his lawn is high
because he could be playing basketball
the opportunity cost to me is low
because I can't play basketball yeah
that's a weird educates I won't do that
then there'd be no true then there'll be
no reason for that makes trade things
hard look we can come back to that now
of course the example doesn't stop there
should I mow my lawn no I should not mow
my lawn because there is someone who's
who as doesn't have as much education as
I who canter as much money and I at work
and they have a comparative Japan gin
lawn mowing I care advantage in office
work so in fact the only should I'm
alive carriage over LeBron in lawn
mowing but some less educated the guy is
a comparative Ange over me in lawn
mowing so just as LeBron be better off
letting me mow his lawn and I've got
after letting him play basketball I'm
better off letting some less educated
guy mow my lawn and letting me go sit in
my cinema from my computer all day okay
comparative image is all about what
you're relatively better at and the key
insight okay of international trade is
that in a world of comparative advantage
people should always specialize in a
world of comparative advantage people
should always specialize you should do
what you're best at okay
you should do what you're best at
because otherwise it's simply silly for
LeBron spent any time only as long as
much as my wife thinks I'm just trying
to get out of it it's simply silly for
you to spend any time mowing my lawn
okay I have a I have a compare advantage
it's study in front of my computer and
doing that stuff so I should hire
someone else to mow my lawn so to
actually see that let's go to figure
eighteen three this is a confusing
figure so I'm going to go through it
slowly okay on the top we have the US
production possibilities frontier and to
make life easy let's assume that there's
no economies of scope between roses and
computers make sense there wouldn't be
right let's assume there's no economies
or diseconomies who knows the computers
it's a linear production possibility
frontier so we're showing each graph is
production possibility frontier between
roses and computers and we're assuming
it's just linear which makes sense right
you don't you don't make better
computers by making Rosen and vice versa
on the top we have the u.s. let's say
that the u.s. is production production
possibility frontiers the following
given the resources we have in the US we
could produce two thousand computers or
one thousand boxes of roses given our
resource our skill level our capital
intensity etc now go to Columbia say
that Columbia given their skill level
resources the sunshine the beautiful
weather any Colombians here sounds
perfect it's like 75 all the time
okay um you end up they can make two
thousand roses and one thousand
computers or one thousand compares or
sub combination in between so the first
things I want to make you hear is guys
understand why these are sensible
production possibility frontiers for
each country the sense of production
possibility frontiers because they
basically show the US has a comparative
advantage in computers that is the
trade-off in terms of roses forgone to
make a computer he's lower in the u.s.
than Columbia okay and Columbia has a
comparative advantage in roses okay the
trade-off in terms of foregone computers
to make a rose is much lower in Columbia
than in the u.s. so comparative ang
members about opportunity cost let me
say it again the US has a comparative
advantage of computers cuz to make a
computer we have to give up less roses
than Columbia does to make one computer
we give up half a box of roses that's
the slope of this line Columbia to make
one computer has to give up two boxes of
roses so we have a comparative advantage
in computers yeah
that's the term comparative you can have
an absolute event in this simple 2x2
model you've ever ancient multiple
things in life but the simple model you
can have the absolute advantage of both
but you can't have a comparative
advantage of both that's absolutely
right in this model with two goods in
two countries each country has a
comparative image of one thing or the
other okay or there could be weird edge
cases but generally that's right okay so
so now I did compares now it's flip and
do roses in roses for the u.s. to
produce a box of roses they have to give
up two computers for Columbia to proves
a box of roses they only give up half a
computer so they have a comparative
advantage in roses okay
people understand the setup here these
graphs on the left yeah so for right now
we're ignoring prices we'll come back to
prices later but right now are doing the
prices right now we're just sort of what
we're gonna basically have prices coming
in later but for right now we're doing
prices okay so now let's imagine that
tastes are such that consumers in the
u.s. one a thousand appears in five
hundred boxes of roses that's point seen
us and consumers in Columbia what five
hundred computers in a thousand box of
roses I just made this up see see us and
see oh I just made up tastes I just said
let's just make up a case where people
in Columbia like roses better people in
America like computers better and
imagine we do not allow international
trade this is the best case actually the
international trade would be even more
valuable with different assumptions I've
made assumptions which make trade less
valuable than it would otherwise be I've
said look look columbia produces roses
and people there like roses american who
produces computers and people there like
computers but not totally some US if I
still want some roses I'm home and guys
don't want some computers now imagine we
don't allow trait what's the outcome
well in the US we will produce we want
like I said we want a thousand computers
and five hundred roses so will produce a
thousand compete
and will consume a thousand computers so
on the chart on the right you've got
production and consumption for the US
will produce a thousand computers
consume a thousand computers we have to
consume we produce there's no trade and
same with rose will produce 500 consume
500 Colombia's the flip so you end up in
the world with 1500 computers being
produced and consumed and 1500 rose is
being produced and consumed now you
might say that silly computers cost more
than roses we'll come back to prices for
now this is just sort of we're leaving
prices out of it okay the point is given
the tastes I'd suggested with see us and
see oh I just made those up given those
tastes we'll end up in a situation where
every country just consumes what they
produce because there's no trade and the
world's the whole will produce 1500 box
the Rosa 1500 computers okay now let's
say that we allow trade what trade does
is introduce economies of scope why
because trade allows specialization flip
to the next figure
the next figures are figure for the
world imagine the world only wanted
computers that's the point on the y-axis
then us have produced 2,000 M Colombians
a thousand would have 3000 I'm back to
the world only wanted roses the flip
side we have 3000 but if the world wants
both you get more why why is it outward
bending when you allow trade why does
trade this is not a technological change
I'm changing technologically all we've
done is take these two PPF siga buying
that allow trade why does that suddenly
introduce economies of scope because
what a country's get to do compared to
what they were doing before when they
couldn't trade what do they get to do
now specialize the u.s. specializes in
and Colombia specializes in roses by
specializing we can make more because
that's what we're good at
so by training we allow specialization
without training we can't specialize
because some guys new
Rosen's got to make some roses but
that's stupid we shouldn't make roses
which like Columbia make roses okay if
LeBron can't hire anyone to mow his lawn
he's gonna mow his lawn that's stupid
LeBron should hire son mows along play
basketball the time by allowing trade we
allow people to specialize and take
advantage of their comparative
advantages without trade you can't take
advantage of competitive advantage
without trade it doesn't matter if the
u.s. is better person computers or Rosas
what's produced just to turn by people's
tastes okay but with trade you can
specialize and that yields the outcome
we discuss and figure 18 five figure 18
five takes the previous figure eighteen
three and adds trade so let me go
through this the basic the blue the PPF
SAR the same on the left okay same PBS's
before and if you look at point c o and
see us we could have a thousand
computers of 500 rows in the US or a
thousand rows and 500 computers in
colombia but now suppose we allow trade
what happens now what happens now is the
u.s. goes to producing only computers
and colombia goes to brew sing only
roses now let's assume just to make life
easy let's just assume that people
states are proportional so if there's
more computers more roses they just want
proportionally more of each so the US as
the more of both wants a you know two
two computers for every rose and
colombia wants two roses for every
computer that's just their tastes what
happens now is we shift out to these new
levels c-prime us and c-prime colombia
at the new levels the US produces two
thousand computers all the newest
computers colombia produces two thousand
roses the world as a whole ends up with
more flip back to pages and look at the
table on the right the world's whole
ended up with 1500 rows and 1,500
computers now the world's the whole ends
up with two thousand roses and two
thousand computers
what happened nothing changed
technologically st. PPS years before all
the change is by training we allowed
people to exploit their comparative
advantage through specialization without
trading the US was inefficiently
producing roses and Colombia was
inefficiently producing computers with
trading we've now opened up the
possibility that they've been
specializing what they're good at and
the world's the whole ends up better off
okay so and look at both countries both
countries end up with more consumption
the they each get the u.s. gets more
computers so flip back and forth in 1813
eighteen five the u.s. goes from five
hundred rows and a thousand computers to
750 rows and twelve fifty computers
Columbia goes from 1250 roses goes from
I'm sorry a thousand rows in five
hundred computers to 1250 rows and 750
computer computers now the split between
rows computers here is is not
determinate that's just made up I made
up what taste look like the point to see
the point C and C prime that's just made
up what you care about is the bottom
panel we gave us the bottom panel well
you care about is the fact that the
world as a whole now has more rows and
more computers in it and that is the
mechanics of why international trade
expands our production possibility
frontier we have more goods in the world
once we can trade not because I mean you
still simmer Pikachu and [ __ ] when I
allow trade between you and your friend
that doesn't create any more goods each
have two cards but in the real world
that creates trade because of production
allows people to specialize and that's
the beauty of trade alright
well come back next time and do a
welfare analysis of why of talking about
why international trade makes people
better off